all right
welcome to simulation
so pumped for this episode
we are featuring john chavez of dmt
quest
welcome thank you very much for having
me man i've been looking forward to this
conversation and connecting and
just chatting about some interesting
things today right
potentially the most interesting thing
so the dmt's relationship to metaphysics
to the nature of reality
yeah that's an interesting topic for
sure it's something that uh
i think it's been speculated upon for
many many years
even before you know some of the more
modern scientific
endeavors regarding dmt or even
ayahuasca have been taking place
uh the whole concept of even uh the
ayahuasca vine
some of the compounds in that being
called telepathy
really long time ago uh it just offers
some pretty interesting conversation
pieces
it's almost like the crossroads between
uh perception hallucination
and supernormal sort of mysticism
yep
[Music]
i have a couple
pillars in the trajectory that i'm
interested
to cover this metaphysical one we just
began
with will be great and then we have a
lot of the
scientific as well which i'm really
interested
in unpacking the healing also along with
the awakening
and then these objective biomarkers
and then the big sort of
funding component to
hone in on because
that acts as the primary energetic
catalyst for the further
awakening and healing and activation of
the planet so i would like to
i really like this quote and it actually
came from the comments
of the documentary hide it inside
it is the last place we will look
the sioux legend
i love that comment from one of the
viewers of the documentary
yeah yeah when you sort of get to the
understanding that you are the source
of all creation yourself you are that we
are the creator
we hide it ourselves in the place that
we're not gonna look
and that's inside which is also
becoming aware of awareness becoming
aware of being
itself existing the very nature
i am yeah absolutely
and especially learning how to tap into
these states that
i guess give us uh less theoretical
perspectives of how to alter reality and
more
direct experience with that sort of
thing
um i think that's probably one of the
more intriguing things that i've come
across
i guess in my research for the dmt quest
project was that this is not
anything new per se um i think modern
science has been studying
this in various forms for about 100
years or whatnot but
obviously uh indigenous cultures and
other sophisticated cultures throughout
the world have been studying this thing
and
in their forms of science for thousands
ten tens of thousands of years so
yeah absolutely we're it's like we're
trying to remember
some things that maybe cultures from the
past had a pretty good grasp of
yep and this is also another
very popular one
the kingdom of god is within you luke 17
21
right i and my father are one john 10 30
or saint francis of assisi
that which you seek is that
you are that your faith is inside you so
the very
dmt the very
god the very source the very
awareness of being the creator of
reality the very
nature is inside you but it's the last
place we will look
it's so good
yeah and i guess uh when you look at
some of the
purported mechanisms with which uh
endogenous cmt could be upregulated
it almost seems like it's counter to how
society
sort of operates in terms of you know
overeating and shallow breathing and
uh you know a lot of massive electronic
blue light usage at night
things of that nature it almost seems
like cultures that we're tapping into
these altered states without
exogenous substances we're using
basically the opposite of
overeating which would be maybe
something like fasting and instead of
shallow breathing something like
rhythmic breathing and then instead of
uh
you know indulging in electronics and
things of that nature
to mess up our circadian rhythm and blue
light uh some of them would even engage
in things like prolonged darkness so
yeah it's interesting when you look at
uh engineering
the mystical experience and reverse
engineering the missile mystical
experience and then you look at
comparing it how
the modern lifestyle almost seems to be
counted so that
it's it's pretty intriguing yeah those
are huge
points this key to unlock matrix the
indigenous
habits that you're talking about fasting
from overeating rather than the shallow
breathing the very
wimbhoff style breathing the
fasting from technology
with the darkness
with also eyes closed more often
and it also also seems to very much be
this
not only the spirit but also the
remembering
molecule so as we up regulate
dmt undergoing these
awakening experiences there's a
remembering
of ourselves as the infinite
and that this is a cameo an appearance
of that infinite
that seems to be so critical as well the
remembering the game that we play
the endless forgetting and remembering
the hide
and seek through the bailless fail yeah
absolutely you know it's intriguing uh i
recently
wrote a piece regarding uh wim hof
method breath work endogenous dmt and
potentially addressing alzheimer's
disease
in in that sort of fashion and going
through the biomechanics of this
respiration exercise and
how it could potentially either you know
halt the progression of a.d or even
reverse it
and in some of the research that i did
regarding that piece it
ties in the fact that the gamma wave
that we see
that seems to be rather consistent
during endogenous cmt
states you know hypothetically or
exogenous dmt ayahuasca
states that we've already seen is that
for whatever reason
this around 40 hertz wave seems to
correlate with memory retrieval
and in diseases like alzheimer's
they notice a substantial decrease in
the 40 hertz range
uh you know being i guess activated in
the brain for alzheimer's patients so
you know there's periphery studies
indicating that if they up regulate the
40 hertz scammer range that the
memory actually starts to come back and
one of the things that i thought about
in this piece because i tend to look at
the opposites because i think you can
when you study one thing
like alzheimer's disease where memory
sort of degradation
is like the key aspect of that disease
it almost makes you look at well what
would be the opposite
of uh of alzheimer's disease and if
gamma hurts
or the gamma oscillation is suppressed
during
um the alzheimer's state what happens
with if gamma is actually
upregulated to the fullest and it's
interesting because
we're going to delve right into the
esoterics right from the get-go
is that uh it seems as though children
about
five to six years old the that's the
point
in at least from what we've studied is
that
humans have the most upregulation of
gamma
as basically as children and when you
take it
taking concepts of like you stated
remembering remembering who we are
uh for whatever reason it seems like
university of virginia has compiled a
pretty good database of these kids
starting to
you know talk about recollections of
strange things like past lives and
for me it kind of makes sense if you
look at it from a linear perspective of
you know gamma's super suppressed at
alzheimer's and then
maybe when we're in our 30s gamma's
somewhere in the middle range where you
know
we have pretty good cognition and
recollection of things and then you go
even further
where the gammas even further increased
potentially in dodging as dmt is even
i guess uh more upregulated during these
states of kids remembering
it's almost like an overshoot of memory
remembering something that didn't even
occur in this lifetime
so it uh it affords some real intriguing
conversations man i'm sorry if we're
kind of going off course right now
it's great that's perfect
the the entire idea of
what's happening with children as
they're birthed
to have them know themselves
as the source of creation
being mission critical to ensure that
the egoic onion layers of conditioning
don't form
and then it perpetuates suffering and
malevolence in society
so this is mission critical and
also the component of having highest
gamma at that age also is so fascinating
because
that's why as an adult when you reunite
with the nature of reality truly
the well of honey and peace
that was covered by the egoic rock
that what happens is you feel this
causeless joy
and so you get this like satchitananda
sort of
bliss peace happiness and
you bring that to everything you do and
so it's almost like maybe the adult
as they unlock the inner child again
feels those higher potential gamma
activations and there might even be an
upregulation
of dmt when there's a natural awakening
in general
just the natural process of reuniting
with
this is already freedom this is already
perfection
yeah no absolutely i think that's that's
a great point
and uh i mean that it's interesting
right because when we see the exogenous
dmt studies with ayahuasca and dmt the
the gamma up regulation is pretty
consistent and
you know similarly not all the time but
i've heard many anecdotes of people
uh being able to recall or they could
have sworn that they experience
a recollection of a past life during
that
psychedelic experience so it's a
complicated situation but it's
intriguing nonetheless
the very nature of this one
makes me also
very excited because we've had
a multi-thousand-year
mystic traditions pointing at
how to recognize oneself
as the source of creation and
that over the past couple hundred years
spirituality and science
have been doing their best to there have
been some oscillations outward but now
is this big
oscillation inward to unite and so one
of these
keys potentially in the synthesis
of science and spirituality is dmt
yeah absolutely i mean after rick
strassman
released his book following his uh study
in the 1990s
uh administering intravenous dmt to the
subjects and
people reporting consistent uh mystical
experiences
from from the ingestion from the
administration it really kind of spurred
that movement
you got to give a lot of credit to
strassman if you haven't read his book
he went through a lot of administrative
hell
just getting uh his study off so uh
big shout out to strassman for getting
that done and you know that took place
in the 90s his book was published in
2000
and then in 2010 dmt the spirit molecule
the documentary came out which a lot of
people saw
joe rogan was the the host of that
documentary
and that caused the conversation to go
even further into mainstream
culture of people just speculating on
dmt and what its role is in the in the
human body
up until that point there had been
studies showing that dmt
endogenous cmt was found throughout the
body cerebral spinal fluid and certain
tissues things
like that but the pineal gland study
that they did at university of michigan
that didn't come out until 2013
and that really spread even more
interest into definitively
i guess finding evidence for what
strassman had
hypothesized in his book that the pineal
gland
uh was a sword a source not necessarily
the only source
of dmt in the brain obviously this was
done in animal studies because to do
this in the human
is a little bit overly invasive and
dangerous and
probably wouldn't get whatever approval
by whatever governing body in the
medical field
and then in 2019 you know this is what
the documentary the dmt quest
documentary was focused on was the
university of michigan study where
they found that dmt is produced not only
in the pineal gland but throughout the
choroid plexus and the cerebral cortex
of not only just live animals but
in vitro tissue sampling also found the
the necessary precursor enzymes to find
dmt
uh throughout the brain so that changed
the whole conversation
of whether uh you know the pineal gland
was the only source of dmt in the brain
and whether
the brain was even capable of producing
enough dmt to induce an experience
because
you know we found that dmt was found
throughout the brain
and the second important aspect of that
2019 study
from michigan was that dmt is actually
floating around in
extracellular fluid of live animals at
similar levels to serotonin and dopamine
and just to stay consistent in terms of
scientific analysis you know
what people seem to kind of veer off
course in the debate about
endogenous dmt is that you know we use
these animal models
because the human studies would be too
invasive
but for whatever reason sometimes when
it comes to dmt
people seem to veer off course and
forget that these animal models are very
consistent with human physiology and and
like to say that it's only animal
studies in which
this stuff has been proven but based on
the anatomical similarities and the
genetic similarities
it seems very clear that these studies
should translate to human
human neuroanatomy and neurochemical
balance as well
the funding for the continued scientific
research
leads to really this that we're trying
to bridge the profound
subjective experience of these awakened
very seemingly upregulated dmt
states with objective biomarkers
and this is really the exciting place
because
if you can go where
in a sense neurology meets
union
this has also been described for
thousands of years by the mystics is
shut your noisy mind up and if you
stop ruminating in the past and the
future with all these cravings and
aversions and if you become aware that
it's like the clouds
appearing and disappearing inside of the
very empty
formless sky that is the witness the
observer the awareness itself
if you become really subtle and aware of
that you can then
unite more and more with the freedom and
the perfection
of you being the very source of creation
itself
of all of this infinite creation and you
being the very source and the witness to
it and then there's also the calling
aspect to it which is great
which is that when you silence yourself
and still yourself enough
you can also access your divine
transcendent north star
calling noble aim and unite with that
more and more purely
and then bring that forth into reality
in a pure
service to creation rather than being in
a service to one of your
egoic onion layers and as john also
mentioned that
it's really interesting seeing the
pineal gland
choroid plexus the cerebral spinal fluid
there's a lot of these really
interesting uh the cerebral cortex
there's a lot of these really
interesting zones
of objective biomarker research and
another core component is to do it
non-invasively
that's another massive core component so
the faster that we can fund the science
to do these objective biomarkers
non-invasively
the more quickly we can get the
synthesis of science and spirituality
with dmt and this is also very clear in
the mystic traditions as well as what
seems to be indicated with the wim hof
method and whatnot which is that
your very act of just
slowing down and
consciously breathing itself
and as has been taught in the mystic
tradition with this kundalini the very
energy being drawn up the spine
that cerebral spinal fluid it
really feels like this profound
activation
to potentially have this objective
biomarker of the upregulation of dmt
oh and that's this also image which we
had sort of prepped too which is really
exciting from the
from the dmt quest documentary which is
the
objective science behind the gamma
activation
during the wim hof method
yeah that was that was pretty exciting
and you know just to be honest uh we
actually started to film the second
episode already in which we take more
subjects
do the wim hof method 20 minutes and we
do the same brain mapping because
science a lot of it is based on
replication so that's really what we're
we did a one-person palette study for
the for the first film and then for the
second film we're going to be adding in
all the data from the second study
that's going to be more definitive
because we have more subjects but
yeah the whole gamma wave up regulation
is intriguing
because it affords the discussion of not
just
i guess the supernormal visionary
mystical states connection
with higher self type of discussion but
it also affords
a more grounded perspective of
addressing uh neurological
deficiencies with the gamma wave
something like alzheimer's so
i think that um yeah it's the gamma wave
is necessary because
from what i my perspective of endogenous
gmt is that
as of right now it's the most likely to
be a non-invasive way
to uh present the upregulation of
endogenous gmt in the brain
i mean it's not a a thousand percent i
guess uh
tightened up in the sense of we don't
have the animal studies to verify
whether uh the dmt deficient animals
actually have suppressed gamma wave and
things of that nature to tie it in
in a loctite uh scientific method but
i think it's a good starting point and i
think that's the way that science
tends to start is that you have to have
a rational
sort of foundation and perspective of
how to present something and then
you build upon and you develop more
studies that will either prove or
disprove the theories and
that's kind of where we're at right now
like you mentioned the non-invasive
measurement of endogenous dmt and even
periphery hormones like endogenous 5-meo
dmt is going to be super important going
going forward uh the non-invasive
aspects uh
would be utilized for human studies
which is something that we can't do
right now with the the human brain and
measuring dmt but
if that can be developed if uh dr john
dean gets the funding that he needs to
go ahead and
continue his course and his mission to
go ahead and develop that technology
then
i think in a few years we're going to
see some intriguing
ways to i guess intertwine these sort of
conversations and the data
yes so this is fair to say that the
gamma activation
may be the easiest non-invasive
objective biomarker
well if you want to just take it from
just uh
surface level analysis yes where
you know ayahuasca one of one of the
consistent things with ayahuasca i
believe there's three or four studies
showing that ayahuasca
suppresses alpha significantly
suppresses alpha waves significantly
and upregulates gamma wave significantly
and then there's two dmt
studies showcasing that uh
after administration of dmt or smoke and
dmt that
same thing alpha gets suppressed and
gamma goes up
and in the most recent dmt eeg study
it seemed as though the strength of the
alpha or the strength of the gamma wave
oscillation increase was directly tied
in with the intensity of the visionaire
experience from dmt
so you know if we want to look at it
just from that perspective of the
exogenous
uh effect the the effects of exogenous
emt and ayahuasca
on the brain and you know translate that
into
potentially indulging cmt up regulation
then i i think it's a pretty decent
starting point the gamma weight
for non-invasive correlation with uh
endogenous cmt i think it's a pretty
pretty good start
hell yeah especially because we already
have
the eeg technology so refined over the
last couple of decades
and especially because we already have
this popularization
of the wim hof method or the
popularization of the
monks as well where we can actually
take this systematically reproducibly
scientifically methodologically
do it repeatedly until we have
in in essence until we basically have
this showing up
repeatedly and then it's like okay so
gamma activation is one of the
greatest non-invasive objective
biomarkers
and then we can maybe wander ourselves
into okay well how about we
do things like how do we specifically
measure non-invasive up regulation of
dmt
itself and so yeah yeah how do you where
do you feel like that might
happen well i in speaking with john dean
he was featured in the first documentary
it'll take some time it'll take you know
a year or two
or maybe a few years obviously based on
the funding the more funding the the
quicker
the the results um but it would be a
magnetic base
sort of uh measurement i don't want to
go into the specifics because first off
i can't explain it
properly and secondly it's john dean's
project so
i don't really want to get into exactly
what he's working on but
um yeah that would be a a game changer
i think that would be a really good look
for endogenous dmt research especially
pertaining to humans
and from what i've spoken with him about
is that he see
it seems as though he can get very
specific so it wouldn't just be uh
endogenous cmt measurement it would even
be maybe endogenous five meow dmt
maybe a dodge's bufodine which is
another form of dmt
and uh not not to forget about uh
the fact that the body produces or the
human nervous system actually produces
endogenous monoamine oxidase inhibitors
as well
so when people talk about ayahuasca and
the reason
why we have such an extensive experience
taking ayahuasca over hours rather than
minutes like dmt
is because there's monominoxidase
inhibitors in the in the shamanic brew
and that's why it's interesting that uh
the human body actually produces
multiple kinds of monoming oxidase
inhibitors
uh tribulate neural cadden epineline
and i think harmon nor harmon are other
ones so
it's multiple kinds we have a very
complex endowaska soup
within us and i think that adds even
more evidence that
uh the mammalian system and the human
system in particular
are there these are i just happen to
believe there's a reason why we have
this complex soup within us that can
induce these sort of
mystical spiritual experiences
oh yeah
so it may be
that our
union with
god right the word entheogen
means unleashing god within unleashing
the divine within
versus psychedelic meaning mind
manifesting it's it's just not
as accurate of a describer as entheogen
antiogen is a better describer for what
these incredible substances do
and so let's say that
you are a
one of the listeners let's say is in a
process of
wondering you know why did i incarnate
what is my purpose here
and so then the way to
identify the answer to that
is to calm down the noisy mind like we
talked about earlier
and to leverage so that's the shut up
piece and then to
activate where neurology meets union
with god unleashing god within the
diamond that's already around your neck
but that your mind is too loud and you
can't tap in
to that well of honey of peace
and joy and your calling your divine
calling your union with god what you're
here to do what you came here to do
how you came here to be in service and
so i think this is a fascinating places
the union whether it's you know pineal
choroid plexus cerebral cortex
just the very the gamma activation the
up regulation of dmt
the very meeting place of neurology
with god with your calling how do you
feel about that
yeah you know one of the interesting
things that i've come across
is that while we mentioned the gam
activation which seems to be a faster
oscillation there
seems to be a relationship between
inducing
slow wave which is uh like calmness like
a theta or a delta wave
delta wave is actually seen more
predominantly during sleep states or
non-rem
sleep states there seems to be almost
like a coupling
between the slow wave and the fast wave
we see like a
synergy between both and like you said
once we calm the mind
we uh quiet the mind it allows us to go
ahead and tap into
higher insights and and god if you will
and it seems as though it's almost like
a rubber band so you pull the rubber
band
like deeper into the calmness and the
quiet and then it just snaps
and uh that's when we have our our
moments uh
you know our insightful moments
our transcendental moments and
um yeah there's there seems to be some
magic there and at the same time
uh there's different ways to access uh
supernormal states right i mean
there's been reports of people uh like
soldiers on the battlefield having
out-of-body experiences and there's no
calmness in the battlefield it's all
pure chaos and trauma so there's i
i guess what i'm getting at is that
there's different pathways
uh to having these mystical experiences
and
it seems as though you know if we want
to go about it in a certain manner
of of cultivating ourselves in a
peaceful manner
then we could do it through quieting the
mind quieting quieting ourselves getting
into our breath
and connecting with a higher self but
you know there's also the other
traumatic pathways that can be induced
to have mystical experiences as well
you know i'd be curious about your
thoughts about this one
as well so in essence
using breath whether it's wim hof method
or whether what we were talking about
earlier with mysticism just becoming
aware
of oneself as the very source of
creation the source of awareness and
being itself
tapping into that calling the north star
the undergoing the process of purifying
itself away from the distorted
ego identities of the onion layer and
more and more towards being a pure
service to the creation and theogens
unleashing the divine within potentially
all of this
being the neural signatures of divinity
so whether that be an endogenous uptake
in dnt and up regulation in dmt
and also serotonin dopamine
but just the simple idea that are there
these profound objective biomarkers
these neural signatures of divinity
and how can we match them with these
with the spiritual
yoga union mysticism hypnosis wim hof
method breath work
calling work all the stuff that tony
robbins and jordan peterson and gary
vaynerchuk talk about was
self-actualization
yeah there definitely seems to be a lot
of overlap at least in my research
i mean there is a significant shift from
baseline so everybody has
you know their baseline of you know
you're talking you're active you're
driving to work you're at work or
whatever so that's kind of like our
general
normal societal baseline and then you
have
you know the brain activity that takes
place outside of baseline
sometimes you know people would say
that's like right when you wake up in
the morning or right before you go to
sleep that's
uh you know the most consistent altered
state that people get in if they don't
have a practice like meditation or
breath work or anything like that
it's uh right before you go to sleep or
right after you wake up you're almost in
the in between state
and it's interesting because it seems as
though a lot of magic happens in those
in between states outside of baseline
and that's part of tapping into the
magic of life i think that's why i mean
a lot of my research
is in regards to all all altered states
not just wim hof method but
things like hypnosis things like
meditation
yoga sensory deprivation light
stimulation magnetic stimulation
they all have been observed to induce
mystical states because they take us
outside of our baseline consciousness
right
our baseline consciousness is the
predominant consciousness
in which much a society likes to operate
on but it might not be our optimal
uh you know brain activity you know it
might not be optimized so
yeah yeah i love how you added sensory
deprivation there's lucid dreaming
there's the
there's sound bathing nature therapy
light stimulation there's all of these
different
sort of
experienced designs that are emerging
out of the matrix that are trying to
elevate people
out of the matrix slowly
and that that's really a lot of it is
about
finding also these it's kind of funny
because when you look at
the way that spirituality for thousands
of years is like
hey you know nature therapy go walk
around in some trees and
you know calm down the noisy mind and
calm yourself out of your
nine to five doing what you're doing and
then you know science like 10 years ago
is like well let's go ahead and do some
scientific studies around decreased
cortisol levels from people that go and
walk into the
forest and it's like yeah like this
shit's so
crystal clear already but yeah go ahead
johnny come lately mr science
go ahead and come and validate yeah
yeah yeah i mean that's that's really
it's funny that's what i'm saying it's
almost like we're remembering uh where
we came from or what we used to know
pretty much at the forefront of like
society in the past cultures from the
past
and um you know the whole nature aspect
is pretty intriguing to me because
i don't know if you're pretty familiar
with the whole fibonacci sequence and
the whole fibonacci sort of
aspect of nature and i think the
fibonacci
uh is actually almost a hypnotic within
itself if you stare at something with
that pattern in it
and so part of me wonders if just being
around nature you're around all these
plants that have the fibonacci sequence
pretty much
everywhere and it's almost like you're
looking at your subconscious is looking
at hypnotic pinwheels
you know all over the place and that
just calms you like in a subconscious
autonomic way
but um yeah there's so much to parse out
with the ways that we can induce altered
states and
and calm ourselves in order to reach
higher higher states of consciousness
when i look at this what do i see
i see myself
yeah it's like an infinite pattern right
yeah welcome to
[Laughter]
you know yeah
or also another one of our really close
friends over at
maths town
you know this is their work right
um you know in essence
we're doing it again yeah you know
that the benoit mandel brought
fractal zoom is this which is
as john was just mentioning
the golden ratio the fibonacci sequence
so when you basically begin
in a sense jumping between these
patterns
and you're like okay that is this
which is infinite creation
and we are that which is the source
of infinite creation
it's just so simple and the more that
you connect
with that truth that is already inside
of you
the more you get these potential
objective
neural signatures of divinity which we
can measure scientifically let's fund
that
but also you just literally feel
like truth you feel like god you feel
like
peace you feel like joy you emanate out
like the sun
enlightenment
yeah yeah absolutely i'm i'm with you
100
um you know one of the things that i
like to bring up is that
while you know dmt quest is largely
about
obviously the molecule and and the
reason for
you know the cluster of molecules like
dmt-5meo all the maois in the body
there's also the concept of you know
consciousness being more akin to
magnetic field i think
a fellow's name was joe mcfadden who
has written a a theoretical piece about
this last year that was pretty
fascinating and then
you have michael persinger and todd
murphy doing interesting work with the
ultra weak magnetic field stimulation on
the brain
and that uh you know that's that's one
of the interesting things to talk about
the eeg data is that you're referring to
electrophysiology of the brain during
these altered states and that correlates
with the
uh you know electricity and magnetism
you know
pretty much hand in hand you can't have
one discussion without the other
so when you start to discuss things like
magnetic fields
then you start to discuss the
possibility if consciousness
is tied in with a magnetic field then
you have the
the natural discussion that goes into
the potentiality for consciousness
expanding
past the physical body because you know
our magnetic field can expand
expand past our physical body and
you know for any of you who have doubts
about that i mean look at the mag device
that
that measures the magnetic fields of the
brain and it doesn't even touch the
scalp
obviously it's close to the skull but it
doesn't touch the scalp so the question
it's not a question of whether our
magnetic field of our body can extend
past our physical body
the question is at how far
in terms of distance can it expand past
our physical body
can we influence something objectively
past our physical body
and at what strength could that occur so
yeah it's uh there's so many layers of
discussion taking place
and i think they're leading to some
really interesting insights for sure
yeah this is a really profound one on
these
neural signatures regarding the
electromagnetic fields there seems to be
more and more developing
scientifically as well which is really
exciting also the
the heart math institute
is also doing really interesting work
with the torietal
field itself when you have greater
coherence
versus when you have the dissonance
which is another
interesting biomarker would you say i'm
curious would you say that the main
biomarkers
right now are we mentioned already
using eeg for gamma activation
is one of the main ones and that's also
been done with meditators and yogis as
well
and people using antiogens etc
we've also seen symmetry and coherence
be another word that is used rather than
dissonance
as a for valence for like a state
of being um then
another good one which i saw you guys
also talked about a little bit in the
documentary as well was
heart rate hearty variability is another
good one in terms of when you have a
when you have a heart rate variability
that is greater it means you're less
stressed
whereas when your heart rate variability
is lower
it means you're more stressed and so
you're more you're more relaxed when
your heart rate variability is
higher and so that's another
potentially interesting one so what
would you say are the main ones that we
should be looking at funding and doing
scientific research
in as these neural signatures of
divinity
i think all of them i think all of them
that you mentioned are important
you know obviously i think the the
animal studies at university of michigan
are
important in terms of solidifying you
know the physical
you know non i guess debatable sort of
aspects of that
those neurological components but yeah
when it comes to human studies i think
heart rate variability incor
in connection with uh you know
alterations in one's uh
oscillat oscillation signatures like
like the gamma wave or the theta wave or
the coupling of those
i think those are important um
even even different ways to measure i
guess uh brain activity can
can be utilized meg might be an
interesting one but
there's so much overlap with the eeg
that might not be necessary based on
cost
uh and obviously the the one that that
dean's going to be working on so
i mean in terms of human human studies i
think that's kind of just our found
our foundational aspect because you know
we can go
deeper into using different types of
equipment to i guess
uh present a picture but i think if you
can't solidify
the basics first and your foundation
first then you're just kind of going to
be scattered all over the place
so i think the gamma wave and the eeg
stuff is a pretty decent starting point
and then you could add in the heart rate
variability stuff as well
yeah cool so for those interested it's
written right there
for gam activation fmri eeg
for heart rate variability ekg
so tapping into those tools that exist
now and also the idea of
so using these for these neural
correlates of divinity
as well as the
building new tools themselves that have
yet to be discovered
that enable to do things like very
easily
provide us with these objective
biomarkers what do you
also think about for example we had
rupert spyra on the show
last year and
his answer to when i was talking to him
about these
objective biomarkers
of awakening was that
we can look more towards
the causeless joy and imperturbable
peace
being an embodied realized state
rather than brain scans and i see the
argument for both
coming together but curious how you feel
about
even just the alignment to
the subjective itself being such a
priority yeah
well i think both is would be necessary
um
and it wouldn't be you know cost
prohibitive to do both so you might as
well
but i think absolutely uh i think that
internal sort of effect is is important
and see if there's any sort of changes
in the sense of people that don't have
that sort of
divinity within them during those
experiences uh
i mean obviously right now we're talking
about the naturally cultivated
aspect of indulgence cmt but there's
also you know the people that have
traumatic experiences from taking
from taking dmt as we saw in rick
strassman's trial not everybody had a
positive experience right
so it would be interesting to compare uh
the changes in the subjective experience
along with the eeg scans
and then comparing to other people that
have really good experiences so
yeah i think spear is on on point with
that because i think that just
discarding the subjective
is a bit silly i mean i think you know
science can go a little too far
where it's like everything's just
subjective needs to be thrown out and we
can only look at objective measurements
i think that we're we're forgetting that
this is the human experience
we are the human experience is first and
foremost right
the subjective experience is first and
foremost
and we're trying to parse out some of
the mechanics of the subjective
experience
with the objective measurements but we
can't put the objective
first
that's a really good way to put it so
basically
do the activities that quiet your mind
that bring you more and more into the
well of
peace and joy that is already within you
connecting to
divinity subjectively and as you do that
naturally we will also create the tools
and objective biomarkers that
that measure that so don't wait for the
objective biomarkers to get really good
before
saying okay now i'm ready to do these
practices
so don't don't jump to that yeah you
know one of the interesting things i
mean
a lot of people look at the wim hof
method from like a purely objective
physical process right like the cold
showers and the cold exposure are good
for
like alleviating inflammation and things
of that nature but
you know there's the other aspect of the
cold in which it's so
uncomfortable that it forces you to
focus
you can't your mind isn't wandering
you're not thinking about you know what
you have what you got to do two hours
from now you know or or
whatever stress you have from last week
the cold is
so uncomfortable for most people that
the mind has to have a singular focus
and that within itself can be very
transformative to people that have a
really busy mind
so it kind of forces you in in a
mechanical way via that cold exposure
to really quiet down and hone in into
that inner peace
if you can find that if you can overcome
the initial shock
so yeah there's there's it's interesting
how there's different perspectives
different angles of looking at the same
exact thing
yes
so this is on dmtquest.org
so the link for this is in the bio
as well as the dmt quest documentary
and this is under the
about and then the future research
and so you can see that the focus on
endogenous dmt research
is a main priority
in several several ways and just like 10
plus ways of diving into this
at a deeper level i mean there's so much
to do here and the only thing holding
back is
really the funding and
oh my gosh we're up to 30.
you guys are nuts you've really
identified all of the different
science i mean that's just a start too
it's going to sprout off into so many
other things right i mean and
and the real vision too is to develop uh
you know well-produced documentaries to
call to go along with all the studies so
they can be sort of presented in
layman's terms so
the general public can better digest the
data and
understand the implications and maybe we
could even add in
little tips and how to tap into these
things you know i don't want to just be
solely research based there needs to be
a media component
and a marketing component to it all so
it has the impact on society that it
needs because
you know i'm sure that you've seen just
like i have
you've seen like this amazing science
that's
takes place and then the media doesn't
cover it and there's no documentary on
it so it kind of just sits by the
wayside so
you know i'm not trying to let that
happen for a topic like this i think
it's too important
the implications are too massive to not
make sure that it gets out into the
public sphere
it's such a beautiful way to put it is
really bringing together the media
component
with the scientific spiritual research
components
and merging those because you know we're
here in
los angeles the show is the studio is
and one of the best
north stars for us here is to really
weave
in the realizations from spirituality
and science
into hollywood right the
whole idea of leveraging the
clout and the influence that hollywood
has to bring
awakening to the matrix
yeah absolutely i think it's time i
think it's been a long time coming
i've seen a lot of people over the past
decade or so have these spontaneous
awakenings
awakenings of sorts and a certain
awareness that you wouldn't expect from
certain people
and uh i feel as though it's it's even a
time for applicability of alleviating
disease so i think it's multi-prong i
think it's important
to remember that this their spirituality
is a component of it but i think that we
can intertwine
uh functionality that will i guess drive
interest from people that might not
necessarily
have spirituality at the forefront of
their minds but they do have a loved one
who is suffering from some sort of
illness that
you know this research could possibly
help reverse or alleviate
you know yeah
the our friends over at maps we've had
rick dublin on the show several times
multi-disciplinary association for
psychedelic studies
what you see repeatedly now is
the leveraging antiogens for healing
anxiety
depression ptsd for
healing addiction for helping end of
life
for you just you'll never get to the end
of all of the different ways that the
both use of the
exogenous substances that
create the endogenous upregulation that
then
creates the union with
divinity and also the
sort of wim hof method style
techniques of endogenous creation
of setup regulation for those
activations of divinity and so you will
never come to the end of all these ways
to sort of like cut and dice up
the ways of science to synthesize the
spirituality and to activate these
higher states but
media really does the sort of like
perceptual shift component
of it which is so critical to sort of
get somebody
to go after they watch dmt quest
to basically go well
wow little did i know that
we actually have some scientific
biomarkers around spiritual awakening
and that's and it's not only spiritual
awakening to
recognizing yourself as the source of
infinite creation
but it's also recognizing on an
awakening side
that i have a divine transcendent
purpose and north star
of why i'm here and to align myself with
that
that's the self-actualization side along
with the self-realization side which are
ultimately
two sides of the same coin
so yeah there's huge practicality in
utility
with this yeah absolutely and the thing
is people need to remember uh
you know not every mystical experience
is going to be full-blown
interaction with beings or the higher
power
or words you know you're going to be
hearing voices or things of that nature
they can be a little bit more subtle
so i think part of it is quieting the
mind and
quieting the lifestyle in certain
aspects to
uh realize when these signs are coming
to you
you know uh i think that's kind of one
thing
it's almost like bringing us back to our
intuition i think that
uh for whatever reason society has kind
of
seemed to i wouldn't say on purpose but
it's
just a byproduct of the way society is
these days is that it
it kind of has ripped people away from
their own intuition their inner knowing
their inner self their inner confidence
and
part of these practices help to realign
oneself
with uh you know greater intuition and
because i think that comes from a higher
cell is intuition
you know i think that's important yeah
there's so much will and choice and
sovereignty
that is frozen in the matrix scripts and
algorithms and
slowly as you unfreeze that
will you gain more and more spiritual
mass and you connect to this higher self
and this intuition that channels through
that then access this guidance in your
life
yeah yeah absolutely yeah one of the
things i wanted to mention real quick
was uh you know thomas edison he's one
of the most i guess
one of the most well-known inventors of
somewhat modern history is that
he actually actively use altered states
to tap into
abilities to i guess come up with
solutions that he couldn't come in
couldn't come up with in his normal
baseline consciousness
and a lot of people aren't really aware
of that so
he had a method to induce hypnagogia in
which uh
he would sit in a chair a rocking chair
and kind of just rock back and forth
until he fell asleep
but he would passively focus on uh on an
issue that he was having
problems uh solving and he would hold
like two heavy metal balls almost like
shot puts
and basically he would just rock back
and forth until he fell asleep and then
the balls would fall on the ground and
then they would create a big thud
that would wake him up and in many cases
he reported that
at that moment when he heard the thud
that he would have the solution to his
problem
that he couldn't get during his normal
waking consciousness so
you know for people looking for
applicability or people that
known people that have utilized altered
states of consciousness in a tangible
manner
that's just like one example but there's
been many luminaries of the past that
have been uh documented to utilize
altered states to tap into
you know higher abilities i adore that
story so much
it's one of my favorites i love that one
yeah the analysis of this meta pattern
of the most genius people that have ever
lived is that
they very very frequently have used
these sort of life hacks or
biohacks to access these
states of divinity and creativity and
that
you you almost have to
this source of infinite creation
leverages
this design where we contract our energy
into this very finite egoic
sense of being and then we have to have
the reality
designed this way you you have to have a
process of hiding
you you can't just birth and know
everything
and so because of that you have this
mechanism
and then you over time you relax
and expand that contracted energy and
then you gain more access to creativity
and you gain more access to
innovation and you gain more access to
this higher self into
knowing yourself as just a cameo
an appearance of eternity of infinity
and blessing the very nature
of your own love story and like really
radically
loving and accepting yourself truly
every one of your 30 trillion cells are
divine and to
especially when you undergo the use of
the substances that upregulate
these neural correlates of divinity what
happens is you are
revealed like a rocket
that you are divine this is divine
yeah now that makes a lot of sense that
uh it wouldn't be fair for us to
remember everything from birth and just
keep that on what would be the challenge
in that right i think that
you know there's a reason why we
incarnate on earth and i feel like it's
a challenging uh
level of i guess evolution spiritual
evolution
and that's really what it what it's
about at least that's just my
perception based on everything that i've
read and things that i feel in my core
i feel like you know that's what this
this level is about
it's about uh overcoming the the many
challenges that we will face
uh when incarnated in this vessel in
this lifetime
and um you know one of the other things
i wanted to touch upon was the fact that
you know back to the whole consciousness
coinciding with uh maybe a magnetic
field
at it at its more uh at its foundation
is uh
even concepts like uh like terminal
lucidity
at the time of death so you'll have
somebody with alzheimer's in which their
brain
is essentially very atrophied so it's
very disconnected
and very shrunken and
you know during terminal lucidity a
person will not be able to
remember anything about their family or
their loved ones for many
for many years possibly and then in the
days or hours or minutes leading up to
their time of transition
then they magically remember everything
very lucidly very clearly
and it seems pretty evident that uh
it's not as if their brain was able to
regenerate the neurons and regenerate
all the neural pathways
within that last hour of death right so
it's not like
uh the brain was able to open up and
then it was able to find the information
within the brain
so there lies the possibility that at
moment
of death or during this term of lucidity
that
the brain is able to kind of generate a
certain
uh electrical oscillation that will
couple with the magnetic field to go
ahead
and recall some of these things you know
recall some
some of the aspects of their life in a
very lucid manner
so it's just a another thing to think
about you know when we're talking about
you know connecting with the divine our
consciousness magnetic fields
our electrophysiology our biochemical
fluctuations these are all things that
are taking place
all at the same time just at different
layers so
it's just uh you know a method of
looking at the human experience and
physiology that's kind of helped me
i i feel like kind of get a certain
uh perspective to to better understand
these strange currencies
yep and in the documentary you guys
referenced it as the life review
as well so terminal lucidity is also
kind of like what is going on that sort
of creates this very
nde style white source light life review
beauty and that's just such a
whoa component to it yeah it's
it's amazing it's amazing that this
stuff is taking place on a rather
consistent basis if
you see the surveys with especially with
nurses not so much with doctors you know
it's probably because they're more
reserved than what they can talk about
but
you know if you look at the surveys of
nurses talking about end of life
transpirations it seems to be very
consistent so
there's probably something there you
know that that's the thing with i guess
my perspective of science is if there's
a consistency in something
uh there's probably some aspect of
reality that
you know it's meant for that and uh we
don't really
hasn't really been tied in with
mainstream conversation of transitions
and things like that but
you know it doesn't mean it's not real
it just needs to be woven into their
into the narrative yeah it could
potentially be thought of as the
the life review as the
sort of giving everything back
to source giving everything back
to shunya to the void to the emptiness
and then getting ready for what is the
next
forgetting and remembering experience to
come in service of infinite creation
yeah that's definitely possible i think
that
i think that's probably going to be the
science of the future is in terms of
mapping that stuff out and actually
interacting with the other side
i think that's and i i don't know how
far away that is to be quite honest you
know i think that
we have some futuristic thinkers uh you
know we've been corresponding
with so you never know maybe within the
next decade we're going to have
the next level of science which is
interacting with the less physical i
wouldn't say the non-physical but the
less physical
[Music]
yeah this is a revolution that's coming
this decade in the next decade it's the
synthesis of science of spirituality
another way to think about it it's the
synthesis of
infinity and infinity so dfinity
is the scientific methodological study
of the form
of this creation and the infinity is
this metaphysical
this is the very source of infinite
creation
that we create as also these witnesses
these observers
this consciousness awareness to undergo
said process of
being just like the dreams the dream
analogy
is such a salient analogy you go and
dream at night when you dream at night
you simulate out the observer and the
reality
and then what happens is there's no
separation where's the separation
between the tree and the house and the
person and you as the observer
there's no separation and so very
similarly with this
we are the manifestation of
this creation in its no separational
ability it's the same
seer god looking through your eyes
as it is through mine and that's what's
meant by this
all-inclusive awareness all eight
billion of these units having the same
in all-inclusive shared
eternal awareness watching infinite
creation
of our own manifestation
and so this is what's probably going to
be like the next couple of decades is
like
how do we create the synthesis of
science and spirituality
and tell this narrative and create it in
vr pedagogy as well
these types of things yeah yeah it's an
amazing time to be alive or to be
you know on this side in terms of the
earth and
human history and things of that nature
i think that
there's no more exciting time especially
if you want to get involved in these
sort of discussions and and moving the
needle and pushing things along
i think you know your whole audience is
is part of that movement so i'm just
happy to be able to chat with you about
it and just spread the word about
you know things that are going on one of
the theories that i presented
i was going to present it at uh terence
mckenna's death anniversary last year
dennis had asked me to present there was
um
we're undergoing a poll shift this has
been this is like
mainstream sort of reporting cnn fox nbc
they've all been
reporting about this [ __ ] that's
been going on uh
over the past i believe five or six
years and it's only accelerating so what
happens when there's a pole shift
uh the magnetic field of the earth
changes it's actually weakening
and these fluctuations in the magnetic
field of the earth
they have uh they can have an effect on
consciousness
and while we're not walking around
you know on a psychedelic experience
like a full-blown psychedelic experience
completely there is the possibility that
uh we are having our consciousness
altered and that this
pole shift and the earth's magnetic
field changes is uh
coinciding with the awakening that's
taking place right now
at least that's what michael persinger's
uh hypothesis was is that
you know the the ultra weak magnetic
stimulation that he would do on people's
brains
uh was upregulating endogenous dmt
you know terence mckenna one of his
theories was the stone eight theory of
evolution
which uh he believes our ancestors
ingested uh
psilocybin mushrooms which led to the
the growth of the prefrontal cortex
which has not really
been explained yet by modern science in
terms of
what was the reason for that jump in the
size of the prefrontal cortex
and um i think that you know the the
endowaska pole shift theory of evolution
is kind of complementary to terence's
theory is that
instead of our ancestors ingesting
psilocybin mushrooms i feel as though
pole shifts throughout history
induce either up regulation or down
regulation of endogenous tmt
causing neurogenesis neuroplastic
changes in the brain
and i feel like we're we're in the
middle of undergoing that right now
wow i love that one that's so good
because stoned ape is also has
scientific
even correlates like the fusion of
chromosomes 2a and 2b
the development of the fox p2 protein so
there are these scientific correlates
around
that as well which is very exciting and
i really like the idea of these magnetic
pole shifts
having to do the very nature of the sun
the sun
is god the sun powers the
energetic secretion that happens on the
planet for there to be this process of
awareness being an observer of creation
with all these appearances of form and
experiences and whatnot
and so for there to be a magnetic pole
shift on the planet with the sun
that triggering a neuro
chemical upregulation
or down regulation of potential
you know stress and up regulation of
more
peace that is hella cool
yeah it's wild i mean and if you look at
even some of the plant studies it shows
that uh
dmt is upregulated when uvb rays
are at their highest and what happens
during the pole
shift is that the magnetic field of the
earth weakens and it actually allows for
more
uvb rays onto the earth which would
point to the possibility that you know
that's one of the reasons why endogenous
cmt is upregulated during these times is
it maybe acts as a neuroprotective
effect you know
as one of the mechanisms but yeah it's
an interesting theory
interesting conversation nonetheless for
sure yeah
i love everything that
john is doing i would highly recommend
everybody to go and check out
dmtquest.org
the documentary the link is in the bio
and so is the documentary link
again it's a movement that will affect
everybody
you know focusing on discovering innate
pathways to unveil the mysteries of
human perception and potential
so guys support them donate
right here the donate button definitely
support them
and they have you know over 40 research
that's going on he's got great blog
posts here
the advisory panel as well you can go
and check out all of this and
definitely highly check out the
recommend checking out under about the
future research as well go and check out
everything they have going on that you
would be donating to
so
guys get behind this guys this is it
look at all these epic you know subjects
dmt could be the missing link across all
spirituality
you know dmt has the spirit in
remembering molecule the key to unlock
the matrix
the analysis of conscious breathing
affecting the
cerebral spinal fluid pulsations to
upregulate
dmt bridging the profound subjective
experience with objective biomarkers
gamma activation maybe an e one of the
easiest non-invasive objective
biomarkers
and these neural signatures of divinity
and quieting the mind to be able to
create this union this purification
this neurological activation
around your calling your very faith is
inside you
and i said in the sioux legend hide it
inside it is the last place we will
look this has been such an honor john
you are an awesome
soul an awesome contributor to this
planetary awakening and we are super
grateful that you came on the show
to talk to us thanks for having me man
i feel like i'm just doing my job and
i'm just having fun with the journey and
connecting with people like you and your
audience and just everybody out there
who's
who's about this movement you know about
not just dmt quest but just about the
human potential and
kind of remembering who we are and just
finding peace within ourselves so we can
uh
you know spread that out to other people
as well you know i think that that's
super important
especially in these weird times so just
uh thanks for having me on and uh
i really appreciate this discussion with
you
likewise we're we're honored to have
hosted you and we hope that
the takeaway one of the main ones for
the audience is
not only tap inward to this inner
kingdom of god that's already within you
but also
support the research of dmt as one of
the main
ways for us to synthesize spirituality
with science
it's so beautiful and again dmt quest
dot org the links in the bio below check
it out
if the video brought you guys value give
it a like it helps the
algorithms also subscribe if you haven't
yet to the channel
comment below with your thoughts we
would love to hear from you
and share the video with those that you
feel like this would resonate with
especially those
that are in this matrix layer that are
looking for
this objective scientific biomarker to
get them to
open up to that heart chakra more and
more
yeah right on thanks so much for having
me on man hopefully we can uh when the
second episode comes out i'll come back
on
we would love that when when is when are
we looking for the second episode
approximately
uh to be quite honest it looks like it's
gonna be out in the fall i mean we still
need to do a little bit more research in
terms of to
to add it into the documentary so we're
kind of waiting on that and um
a few other things but yeah most likely
in the fall of 2021
episode two will be out epic and that's
going to be dmt
quest episode two absolutely awesome
awesome this we're so jacked guys
hit the donate button on dmt quest let's
get this done
okay we love you we adore you so much
thanks for tuning in
i'll go ahead and end the broadcast and
we'll stick in the studio for a minute
right out bye guys see ya